the jurgen experience i struggled with
depression
so much throughout my life even as a kid
i didn't know i was depressed or dealing
with anxiety or whatever but um did you
find different methods that helped you
relieve it yeah well so yeah ultimately
i at 37 i talk about it in the book but
um at 37 when i moved out to austin i
had a whole meltdown and
thank god was surrounded by some friends
and family that helped kind of pick me
up and get me to
uh this program that's up and they
operate out of um southern california
connecticut and i chose to go to
connecticut for three weeks of this like
super intensive life-changing
life-saving therapy
and it was
i threw the psychological kitchen sink
at it it was
three weeks uh every day
at least you know three or four
appointments that were uh one of either
a psychiatrist psychotherapist
dialectic behavioral therapist uh art
med art therapist meditation therapist
life coach nutritionist
gym four days a week yoga twice a week
pilates twice a week and that
helped me tremendously and i learned a
lot of modalities and things from all of
that but that wasn't until you know five
years ago the rest of my life i've been
coping by [ __ ] boozing and drugging
and sexing you know what i mean like i
didn't realize how much self-medicating
i was doing for so long and i wish that
there would have been some way
for anyone to be able to be like let me
just i'm just going to like see what
your levels are right because i i didn't
even know i didn't know that what i was
constantly feeling all the time
well anxiety i was constantly feeling
all the time depression would hit me in
these moments where
basically i'd have massive dopamine
crashes i've as i've i think i've come
to find out like i just i would finish a
job or you know
get out of a relationship or i wouldn't
be working for a while and all of a
sudden it's like i'm worthless i'm
worthless i'm with this work always kept
me bullied if i'm at work it's dopamine
all day long
particularly on a movie set or whatever
like it's all there's a little bunch of
little puzzles you're just solving
little problems all day long yeah double
w
being on a broadway stage you got a
thousand people i mean you know you you
understand the rush of a live audience
[ __ ] you're feeding off of that energy
you know and you're playing jazz with
this crowd i mean it's incredible so
much dopamine and i would get off you
know doing a broadway show
i'd be flying after the show and then i
would go to the bar with some of my cast
mates and i would be drinking whiskey
gingers like till three in the morning
because i didn't even have to be at work
the next day until 6 p.m or whatever it
was all just a ton of self-medicating
because i didn't love myself and i
didn't know that i didn't love myself
wow so you just thought you were
partying yeah basically yeah and so then
i think that's what a lot of people
think you have a moment where it just
comes crashing down is it a moment is it
a series of moments no it was like you
know i had this this big dream still do
of of
moving out here buying a bunch of land
building a movie studio slash arts
commune slash resorts that's kind of
like a new united artist someone sounds
like a cult leader
why do you think i came to texas bro
uh
and so so i had you know head full of
steam and dreams and all that and i was
so convinced like this is what i'm
supposed to do with the rest of my life
i want to make a better hollywood all
these things right and i came out but
i'd like
my my work life wasn't great at the
moment like the jobs i was doing i
wasn't stoked with i was again feeling
like a failure i just broken up with
this girl wonderful girl who was from
austin who probably would have moved
here with me but i self-sabotaged it all
and i was like nah i don't think this is
going to work and i came out here i had
no real support structure and my friends
and family had a beautiful community in
los angeles but i was like i gotta go i
gotta i feel compelled i gotta go do
this i gotta go buy this land and i'm
really grateful that i did but i didn't
do it in the healthiest of ways and so i
ended up out here and i was alone and i
was deeply deeply feeling like oh i've
blown up my life i don't feel supported
i didn't feel like i felt like a lot of
my friends and family were watching me
go in this kind of almost manic state of
like i gotta [ __ ] you know like just if
i don't do it now i'm not gonna do it
and i know i had to get out of
california like california was has been
broken for so long and i love california
i'm from california but it's it's just
so busted in so many ways but so i came
out had nobody had no real support
structure work wasn't great love life
wasn't great all these things were just
like falling down on me and so
massive just
spiral into darkness damn yeah it was
gnarly i mean even went to
um i mean i was definitely considering
killing myself and it wasn't the first
time that i'd ideated on certain
thoughts like that if if if ultimately
committing suicide is
like a ten-rung ladder
i was at rung nine a couple a couple of
times a couple of times in my life yeah
it was gnarly but i didn't realize that
the reason why you get there is because
your hormones are all completely out of
whack my dopamine my serotonin my
norepinephrine all these things that are
to keep you know and me going and
drugging and boozing doesn't help
balance those things either but you
don't know that you're just chasing like
i got to be happy i don't know how else
to get get through all this stuff you
know yeah so all of that just came oh i
quit smoking when i moved here too so
like all this everything it was so it
was so intense but anyway but it you
know this place changed my life it saved
my life but i will also mention though
that
it gave me a lot of understanding of my
own psychology and just psychology in
general i suppose but i i'm learning all
these things about how to like love
yourself more that's great you can learn
all that knowledge but if you still
don't believe that you are worthy of
being loved you won't apply any of it
you don't care about any of it you don't
see the value in yourself to want to put
that work in you know and so thank god
there was this woman
her name is beth in the book she was we
had these like um
uh like companions basically like house
moms because if somebody's not in a very
good place you can't depend on them to
like get up and like make themselves
breakfast and get to your appointments
and all that kind of jazz it was a
a very nice place that really took care
of you it was built for like ceos that
were having massive burnout and all that
jazz like lots of depression and and and
things of that nature but anyway we had
these companions and they would rotate
through lovely women all of them
uh but there was one
beth who
was a mom of three kids just like me and
my sisters middle boy between two girls
and her son also struggled with mental
health
and
it i did she turned out to be
this angel man like this total god loved
me through that woman and the most
intense amazing ways and she doesn't
take credit like she did it she knows
she was just a vessel she was just a
tool that god got to show me
a mother's love like really kind of for
the first not the first time i know my
mom loved me and tried to do her best
particularly
i've done all the therapy i know that my
mom did her best but it still left me
with so many holes particularly with
that maternal
you know trauma and so this woman ended
up at least like just lighting the the
pilot light you know just getting me
started so that i could then you know
take that journey on and go go about it
more on my own